back in the early 2000s lindsay lohan
was one of the most famous celebrities
in hollywood
today however she's pretty much nowhere
to be seen
so how and why has her star fallen in
the last decade and a half
this is why you rarely hear from lindsay
lohan anymore
lindsay lohan has had some pretty
significant and well-documented
difficulties with alcohol and drugs over
the years
as of 2013 lohan had been to
court-ordered rehab
six times while her grand total of
intoxicant-related incidents
is too long to list are you an addict
yeah
now lohan hasn't actually gotten in
trouble for anything
in a good long while but her spotlight
didn't fade
simply because she used to enjoy having
a good time
for one thing her track record quickly
made her an insurance liability on
multi-million dollar movie sets
for another thing lohan's chaotic
personal life began to overshadow her
career accomplishments
indeed most of her heyday projects
didn't have much staying power
and in the minds of today's media
consuming public she's known for mean
girls and the parent trap
and well that's pretty much it the sad
fact is that there came a point at which
lohan was better known for being
self-destructive
than she was for being creative lohan
did at least get some later work making
self-aware appearances
as herself on long-running shows such as
anger management and glee
but while a little ironic
self-deprecation might be funny every
now and again
when it's the only trick a performer can
still pull off it can become kinda
depressing
and once that happens the work dries up
completely
for the most part lindsay lohan's legal
problems have been related to her
substance abuse issues
her rap sheet is a little too long to
list in full but basically
lohan managed to cram the period between
2007
and 2013 full of dui arrests
lightning quick stints in jail probation
violations
and one charge of cocaine procession as
a result
she has had to jump through a bunch of
procedural hoops
and pay a ton of money to boot in
addition
assuming various allegations against her
are true it appears that lohan is
or has been a hardcore kleptomaniac the
troubled star has been accused of
stealing from parties
a wide variety of friends a jewelry
store or two
the wardrobe departments of her own
movies and from ex-boyfriend igor
tarabasov
while it's not quite fair to pass
judgment when you don't know the full
story
it's probably safe to say that this
unfortunate reputation has made execs
and producers think twice about casting
lohan on their
projects of course a celebrity going off
the radar usually means more than just
appearing in fewer movies and tv shows
with that in mind it's worth asking why
has the media seemingly lost interest in
lindsay lohan
well it's partly because she lives in
dubai now which makes her a lot less
accessible to the american press
it also happens to be the case that
during the mid-2000s
celeb centric media developed a fixation
on famous young women who were
enthusiastic participants
in recreational nightlife activities
this included lohan herself
hotel chain heiress paris hilton future
tv personality nicole richie
and perhaps most notably kim kardashian
who swung her brief phase of notoriety
into a media and fashion empire that
carries on to this day
while the kardashian brand may have
flourished however
the media obsession with hilton richie
and lohan had pretty much run its course
by 2010.
that's probably because the public
quickly became worn out from hearing
about the same celebrities getting in
trouble
all the time but maybe after lohan
narrowly avoided felony charges and
hilton wound up doing jail time in 2007
the public stopped finding their
exploits quite so fun to follow
and so the media decided to focus its
attention elsewhere
intended as lindsay lohan's
groundbreaking transition
into edgy adult roles 2007's i know who
killed me was shredded by critics and
largely ignored by moviegoers worse
still the production had to contort
itself around
lohan's court-mandated rehab stints plus
a handful of other lohan related
obstacles although director chris
sivertson has since praised her acting
saying she's got an incredible amount of
raw talent and what she does on camera
seems
almost effortless within the first 10
minutes it becomes immediately obvious
that sivertsen very much wants i know
who killed me to be twin peaks firewalk
with me but is it really fair to label i
know who killed me as discount david
lynch
and toss it aside could it be that the
world of 2007 was simply too sick of
lindsay lohan to give the film an
honest chance well as critic charles
bromesko writes
the baggage lohan dropped off at set
only serve to deepen
and enrich the subtext of a stealth noir
gem one that gestures to a long by gone
era of movie stardom through the
framework of a cheaper and dirtier sort
of serial killer thriller
maybe this one does deserve another
chance after all
the micro budget brainchild of director
paul schrader and writer brett easton
alice the canyons was met with critical
scorn
and it wasn't exactly widely seen either
this isn't necessarily surprising
as it's an erotic thriller with a
serious mean streak
so not exactly mainstream fair still
the film's dead on arrival status proved
that controversy alone cannot always
carry a film to profit
the fact that lohan allegedly couldn't
be bothered to promote the film
probably didn't help matters but more
importantly
a few years after the movie's release a
deluge of sexual
assault allegations ruined the public's
ability to comfortably watch lohan's
canyon's co-star james dean pretend to
abuse a woman on screen
as such it doesn't seem like the canyons
stands much
chance of becoming an ironic cult
favorite anytime
soon but even before all that happened
the production had been caught up in the
ongoing tornado of
upheaval that defined lindsay lohan's
life at the time
it seems reasonable to suggest in
hindsight that maybe schrader
and ellis should have known better
clearly
lindsay lohan's acting career hit its
high water mark with mean girls
ever since she played katie herron
however she's drifted further and
further away from acting
to the point that it has ceased to be
her primary occupation
that is so fetch gretchen stop trying to
make fetch happen
it's not going to happen so if you
wanted to make the case that she's more
than a little washed up as an actress
you could credibly do so but that
doesn't mean she stopped acting
completely
or performing in other ways in fact
lohan appeared in a video on demand
underworldish movie called among the
shadows in 2019
she also showed up on season two of
sicknote alongside rupert grant
and nick frost in 2018 and is attached
to a mickey rourke project
called cursed sure disney's probably not
calling her agent
as much these days but it's not like
she's doing nothing as far as lohan's
music career goes
it may surprise you to learn that she's
quietly started putting new music out
again as of 2020 this ends a long
stretch of inactivity in the music
industry
reaching back to the release of her 2005
album a little more personal
raw whether she's on the way back to her
platinum selling heights of yore however
remains to be seen even nowadays
after drugs and alcohol have ostensibly
been removed from the picture
lindsay lohan's career continues to take
an unpredictable route
as it turns out she's perfectly capable
of getting involved in all kinds of
weird stuff
beyond singing acting and getting into
trouble
unfortunately they haven't all been the
most successful of endeavors
in 2019 lohan appeared as a judge on the
australian version of
the masked singer though she didn't last
very long
meanwhile her mtv reality series lindsay
lohan's beach club
only made it through a single season
before the featured mykonos resort
one of lohan's personal business
ventures seized operations
however people magazine reports two
other greek entertainment establishments
lohan co-owns remain open for business
moreover she made several millions
selling the mykonos location
so at least in this case it seems like
lohan managed to fail upwards for a
change
while lohan has had some success as a
nightclub entrepreneur however
her attempts at humanitarian
interventionism have been a far more
mixed bag
in 2018 she got into a bizarre
altercation in moscow with a woman she
accused of child trafficking
nobody's really sure about the exact
details of what happened or why
but lindsay's behavior in the video
fueled speculation that everything was
far from okay with the star when asked
about the incident by journalists some
time later
lindsay repeatedly dodged their
questions before having a representative
email a prepared statement to paper
magazine
which read i've read the situation wrong
i've learned from it
and that's all i have to say back in the
good old days
if a celebrity wanted to make some extra
money with a high-profile
advertising gig all they could do was
cross their fingers and hope that a big
brand would hire them to be in a tv or
print commercial nowadays things work a
little differently
as brands prefer celebrities to push
their products on social media
lindsay lohan has taken that paradigm a
step further with the uk-based
jewelry company lily baker jules with
which
she co-designed a line of accessories
it's hard to determine lohan's genuine
level of participation or
interest in this venture though after
all celebs do tend to exaggerate their
level of involvement with the products
they slap
their names on but lohan has been
heavily promoting the collection on
social media to the point that she seems
at least somewhat engaged in the
marketing process
considering many celebrities only do the
bare minimum with this sort of thing
it does seem that you can count this as
a genuine career venture from lindsay
lohan
depending on how up to date you are with
financial trends bitcoin will seem like
either one of the biggest fads of the
moment
or little more than yesterday's news one
thing is for certain though
lindsay lohan falls into the former
category in february 2020
lohan tweeted bitcoin to the moon then
days later she followed that up with
bitcoin to mars
now to the moon is a very real phrase
with distinct meaning
in the world of cryptocurrency so it's
clear she does know what she's talking
about
at least on the surface lohan was also
happy to record a cameo video predicting
a grand horizon for crypto but
considering the fact that cameo is about
getting celebs to say whatever you want
maybe that one needs to be taken with a
grain of salt
it's pretty easy to understand how
lindsay lohan might have no idea how to
feel or behave
after receiving good press especially
after the constant mockery and
belittlement she endured from the media
throughout the late 2000s and beyond
indeed
this seemed to be the case in january
2021 when a 20 year old fan named delana
contacted lohan about a proposed cameo
recording
apparently elana was struggling to come
out to her parents so in a tick-tock
video she floated the idea of hiring the
actor to reveal the truth for her
then in her own video lohan responded to
alanna with the following words of
wisdom
that you are about to take a very big
step in telling your parents
you know who you truly are and what you
want them to accept of you
lohan went on to say i think that coming
from you
you'll feel a lot of power and strength
and it's important that you are
who you truly are the cliff became a
minor viral sensation and had the world
thinking that maybe lindsay lohan was
more than a vapid fallen celebrity
cliche
after all then elena was quickly asked
to remove the video from the internet
perhaps all the positive attention she
was suddenly getting made
lohan just a little bit uncomfortable
nobody can know for sure
one thing we do know however is that
even after all this time
it's pretty much impossible to guess
what lindsay lohan is going to do next
and you've gotta give her credit for
that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one